foreign
[Laughter]
so
testing one two
good morning again mr chairman uh
councillors
uh interested parties it is
almost 10 30. i do apologize
um that we had to um
reconvene there was some technological
issues that meant that we couldn't
proceed as planned at ten o'clock
i would like to thank our uh technology
staff support staff
who've been able to fix that uh
particular problem
um and we're now ready to proceed my
name
is david smith i am the legal advisor
today is the 23rd of october 2020.
this is a sitting of baby district
council's
licensing subcommittee and the purpose
of the
hearing today was to review a
premises license under section 51 of the
licensing act 2003
in respect of the caffeine lounge 14
boron gate shopping center sudbury c
co 10 to eg
this um hearing was adjourned from the
first of october
and prior to the setting this morning
the subcommittee was made aware of an
application to
adjourn today's review hearing
that adjournment focused on
disclosure issues which had not been
resolved
in time for all the relevant information
and evidence to be before all interested
parties
in considering that application to
adjourn the subcommittee
as always has had regard to the
licensing act 2003
hearing regulations 2005 and in
particular regulation 12
which gives them the power to extend
time if it's in the public interest
and if there are further matters that
need to be attended to
and the count the subcommittee have
taken the
decision that in these particular
circumstances they would exceed
to the application to adjourn however
given that this
is the second adjournment of an
important
review process and application they have
asked
whether certain deadlines can be put in
place
with regards to ensure that all parties
are
ready and prepared for the adjourned
hearing
uh which will take place on thursday
the 12th of november 2020 at
10 a.m the reason for the deadlines as i
say
is the subcommittee want to ensure that
all relevant parties
provide all relevant evidence and any
requests
for further information are dealt with
in good time to
if we can proceed on the next occasion
the first deadline or first direction
that the subcommittee would ask
can be put in place is that any further
evidence
is lodged with the licensing officer for
baby district council
by 4 pm on friday the 30th of october
and the second deadline if i can put it
that way
is that any further requests
for evidence
and or information
and applications for adjournment
should be lodged with the um
licensing officer for bay but district
council by
4 p.m on friday the 6th of november
2020 those are the directions that the
subcommittee would wish to have in place
um they would hope that that would
enable
the um hearing to proceed
on thursday the 12th of november 2020
at 10 am those are the submissions that
i would wish to make
and in those circumstances i would ask
that today's
review hearing be adjourned accordingly
okay well thank you everybody thank you
david
bring it to a close then uh mr chairman
i've got my hand up
i'll pay it's done um thank you mr
chairman
yes i mean i'm very disappointed that
we've got to this stage again uh mr
chairman
i understand um from what the officers
have said
and i know we have to go down this road
but um
it's the second time the one thing you
didn't actually tell us who actually
asked for this second um a german and
actually who asked for the first one
thank you mr chairman i i do apologize
council
the the um request for the first
adjournment and the request for the
current adjournment were both
made uh on behalf of the license holder
the legal uh advisors for the license
holder made those requests i'm sorry i
didn't make that clear
thank you very much that's fine thank
you thank you peter any any other
comments sue
no thank you okay all right i'll bring
this to your end and look forward to
seeing you all
on the the 12th
thank you thank you
you